I do have a rule that I have learned and  that I believe and that is that the  stronger the resistance that you feel  the more important it is that you do  that whatever it is yeah talk a little  bit about that more because that's  that's really powerful we imagine that  this is our Dream our novel or our  startup or whatever it is the dream is  some sort of unfolding of who you are  revealing like a flower blooming  revealing what's what's there and we set  it out in the sunshine on a on a on a  field or a flat thing like this  immediately a shadow is going to fall  from this thing this is the dream and  resistance is the shadow so the shadow  is exactly  proportionate to the dream so that if  it's a big dream it's going to be a big  Shadow so in other words more resistance  I feel to something the more certain I  can be that there's a big dream there  and that that I've got to do it whatever  the pain is  you know that that's life to get to  there